spider-man is headed back to Sony and
the guys who helped bring him into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are
disappointed but not surprised during a
recent conversation with The Daily Beast
Avengers endgame directors Joe and
Anthony Russo shared their thoughts on
the web-slinger's unceremonious exit
from the biggest film franchise in
history the pair related that while they
and Marvel Studios head honcho Kevin
Feige had been absolutely driven to
bring Spidey into their universe the
shared custody deal with Sony was an
extremely difficult one to get done so
difficult that negotiations to extend it
falling apart didn't register to them as
being terribly surprising Peter Parker
appeared in the MCU for the first time
in the Russo brothers second Marvel
flick Captain America Civil War from the
beginning of the project's development
the directors were adamant that the
story should include spider-man despite
the obvious stumbling block of Sony
holding the film rights Anthony Russo
said we were extremely passionate about
it this is something we really wanted to
happen and fought a long time internally
at Marvel to make it happen there were
of course contingencies in the very
likely event that a deal wouldn't be
struck black panther who was also
introduced in civil war would have had
his role greatly expanded in the event
that Spidey couldn't come out to play
and several other narrative elements
would have been different as well the
movie script went through several
iterations as all of the involved
parties were attempting to reach an
agreement and poor Feige was right in
the middle of it all attempting to
juggle the creative and business sides
of his job in a way that he hadn't been
asked to do before Joe Russo said Kevin
went through a lot there were a lot of
ups and downs and he kept walking into
our office and we'd go look we've got to
do it with Sony and he'd go okay I'll
figure it out and walk back into his he
was looking for the way out he wanted to
open that door and have us go we figured
it out we don't need spider-man because
it's a lot of work to get to major
corporations to play nice with each
other and the fact that it happened at
all we should all be dancing and
celebrating that we got that little bit
of time Anthony Russo agreed saying I
think that's why Joe and I are not so
devastated or surprised that there
Benna falling out because it was so hard
to make it happen in the first place
the Russos make an excellent point the
fact that we got to solo and three
team-up Adventures featuring spider-man
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe is in
itself a minor miracle but this doesn't
do much to ease the broken hearts of the
franchise's fans who had wanted Tom
Hollands Peter Parker to stick around in
the MCU for just a little longer I don't
know what's the matter though appears to
have been settled Sony Pictures chairman
and CEO Tony Vincent Carrick threw cold
water on any remaining dreams fans might
have with remarks he made recently at
varieties entertainment and technology
summit saying quote for the moment the
door is closed
Vince Akira also expressed the extremely
optimistic view that spider-man will do
just fine in the Sony universe of Marvel
characters without help from Marvel
Studios because sure who needs the
Avengers when you have Morbius and
silver sable what is this place to be
fair venom did do pretty darn well at
the box office although it got nowhere
near the critical of that even the worst
received MCU films have we suppose it'll
be cool to see Tom Hardy's Eddie Brock
and hollands Peter Parker squaring off
but let's face facts after the debacle
that was the rebooted amazing spider-man
series it was obvious that Sony had
completely lost its way with Spidey
the MCU resurrected his box-office
fortunes giving Sony Pictures which
reaped all the profits from Webb heads
MCU set solo adventures not only its top
performing spider-man film but the
highest grossing flick in its history
with the wall crawlers MCU swan song
spider-man far from home fans may love
holland but it's hard to imagine his
next appearance in the sony universe of
marvel characters will resonate the same
way his appearances in the MCU have and
who knows how Marvel will have to change
things up now that they don't have
spider-man around I don't think
he did know that you were gonna be here
after he was gone of course there's
still time for Sony to come to its
senses and invite mighty Marvel back to
the bargaining table but at the moment
it appears that the studio is intent on
learning what fans don't want the hard
way again check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite superhero
films are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]